will we run out of fossil fuels or more
precisely will a gradual scarcity of
fossil fuels drive up their price so
that alternatives out-compete them much
of our modern thinking about this is
driven by a very famous 1956 lecture by
a petroleum geologist called M king
Hubbert
he used a bell-shaped curve to predict
the US oil production and correctly
predicted the peak in 1970 in 1973 the
Arab oil shock drove fears of oil
scarcity that persisted this day but
Hubbard did not predict correctly the
future of US oil production which has
since rebounded but since that time
fears about Peak Oil fears about an end
to the oil age driven by scarcity have
centered around Hubbard's prediction of
a peak my view is that we are threatened
more by the abundance of fossil fuels
than by scarcity of course there will be
local scarcity of some fuels and there's
a turbulence in the push and pull
between oil supply and oil demand but
there are at least four forces that in a
long run suggest that fossil fuels will
be widely available
the first is technological change the
second is the geological diversity of
the resource the third is price
elasticity and the fourth is inter fuel
substitution and conversion in the next
sections we'll explore these four
factors in order and look at how they
explain the history of oil production in
the world first technological change the
technologies for finding and extracting
oil and gas just keep getting better two
examples one is the shale gas revolution
where technologies for drilling long
horizontal wells and for making
fractures in precise locations that
allow the oil or gas to seep out of rock
that otherwise would be too tight to
impermeable to allow it to flow
naturally have allowed an enormous
expansion of US oil and gas production
using new technologies second the
gradual increase in the size and
efficiency and now automation of mining
equipment allows very large-scale coal
production at ever-declining costs
second geological diversity when one
hears about an oil resource it's very
tempting to imagine
a fixed reservoir like a tank and
imagine that as that tank is gradually
depleted you get to some point where
it's all gone that's true for some
conventional so-called volumetric oil
reservoirs but hydrocarbons occur in a
vast diversity of forms there are
immense reservoirs for example of
Canadian oil or tar sands that are well
known deposits it's easy to know
precisely where they are but they're
very expensive to extract and turn into
oil there are other deposits like ultra
deep fines recently made off the coast
of Brazil or production is well
understood but finding them is very
difficult when you look across the whole
world there's enormous diversity of
different kinds of oil and gas
reservoirs and that diversity means that
there's no reason to think about a
single fixed supply there are larger and
larger supplies of materials that are
harder and harder to get at third price
elasticity when prices go up people work
harder to get the oil you can see this
in this time series that shows the oil
price along with a number of working US
oil rigs see how the two moved together
they're correlated indeed the technical
definition of oil reserves is the amount
of oil that can be produced using
current technology at the current market
price this means that if oil price
suddenly goes up oil reserves actually
go up overnight
with no change in technology and no
change in the actual oil in the ground
oil reserves are in this sense partly an
economic definition the McKelvey box
provides a good way to think about the
role of price technology and geology in
determining the availability of resource
like oil and gas this is a system that's
used by economic geologists studying
both oil and gas and other resources
like say minerals the vertical axis
shows the cost of producing a resource
with current technology while the
horizontal axis shows the certainty that
resource exists geological certainty so
you can think about existing oil and gas
reserves or resources on these two axes
the Canadian oil or tar sands for
example are geologically certain and
that we know precisely where they are
but the cost of accessing them the cost
of extracting that oil from the sands
and turning into marketable product
been very high although it's gradually
declining as the technology improves
finally the fourth factor driving the
availability of fossil fuels is inter
fuel substitution and conversion
substitution is when a user for example
a electricity plant can choose between
using gas or coal and oil and so they
shift to the cheapest fuel this means
that when one fuel is scarce they can
shift to another fuel and this provides
a kind of economic interchange between
the three fuels as well as an economic
interchange when users actually switch
it's physically possible to turn one
fuel into another for example we can
turn coal into a gaseous fuel so called
coal gasification and we convert gaseous
fuels into liquid fuels so called gas to
liquids so in the world today we both
turn coal all the way into liquid fuels
much higher value fuels that are used
for transportation and we turn natural
gas into liquid fuels this conversion
allows another kind of substitution
separate from the economic substitution
it means that even if one fossil fuel
runs short for example that we run out
of oil running out of oil doesn't mean
running out of hydrocarbon fuels
produced from fossil fuels because we
could produce that same oil from coal or
gas to review we've examined four
factors that shape the long-run
availability of fossil fuels first
technological change second geological
diversity third price elasticity and
fourth inter fuel substitution together
these have shaped the history of the oil
age since the 1850s as an example look
at the global history of oil production
note for example that between about 1930
and 1973 the price of oil was roughly
constant in inflation-adjusted terms
while the quantity of oil increased
tenfold how did that happen it's the
story we've been telling a story of
technological change increasing ease of
access competing against scarcity of the
easy resources and over that time period
is a competition between those two came
out about even but note the sharp
discontinuities discontinuities in 1973
and since then has some of this cotton
you
in the late 19th century those were
caused by regional pushers in Pola
turbulence between the dynamics event of
oil production and oil demand there's no
doubt that the turbulence and oil prices
will continue I don't claim to be able
to predict oil prices a year or five
years hence a single disaster natural
disaster or attack on for example the
major Saudi loading terminal could drive
oil prices enormous Lehi while a global
economic recession could drive that much
lower what these factors do is predict
that the long-run availability of fossil
fuels is large and then it's unlikely
that in the long run sheer scarcity of
fossil fuels will limit our ability to
use them at least not for centuries